Now it's your turn to add the functionality to
create conferences, to your application. First though, you need to
copy over some files into your project. In the
lesson four folder, you'll find Conference.java, and you're going to need
to copy it into the domain package, in your
project. And you can just drag and drop it from
wherever you downloaded it, right into the domain package
in Eclipse. Also, go ahead and copy over the ConferenceForm.java
file and put it in the form
package. Conference.java and ConferenceForm.java files contain completed code,
but don't worry, we haven't done everything for
you. You're going to need to copy the skeleton
version of createConferences into the conference API class,
and it's going to be your job to finish
implementing, the createConference function. After you drag and
drop your files into Eclipse, you're going to
need to refresh your project. Go ahead and right-click on
the project name and then you choose Refresh, and then your
project will refresh, and it'll show the files that you just
copied over. If you forget to refresh it, you might not
see the files, and then you might be in a
panic where they are. So, remember to refresh. When you've copied
the files and the function into your project, go ahead and
have a look at the Conference.java file and the ConferenceForm.java. So
now, here's a quick question for
you. Does ConferenceForm have properties that map
to these properties in Conference? Does
ConferenceForm have a property, that maps to
the name property in Conference? Does it have a property that maps to
the topics property in Conference? And so on. So, just check all that apply.